hello this is Doug Walker and with me is
my good pal and Indian friend yes I'm
very Indian power gone this is our dojo
no Mirage yeah Shawna Mirage this is the
bar go the bargain what just called the
bargain we're gonna talk about Teddy
Ruxpin here because Bargo actually
helped me film this and we actually
tried doing this a few months earlier
you remember we it was like five months
earlier we're trying to film it but uh
Teddy broke and he kept he kept eating
the tapes so so we just kind of
postponed it turned out really good
because this turned out to be a
Halloween special which is really great
and we worked really long as we did it
all in one night and it 3:00 in the
morning that right no 4:00 4:00 in the
morning yeah no it was fine too because
I remember like you were you're just
going in and out of consciousness oh
yeah this was the worst film ever this
is this is just the worst time ever that
I've ever had you think
no for real because I was I was hungry I
was tired and I was sick and I tortured
the fuck out of you it was and yeah this
is just I was I remember like dog if you
want to fucking do this let's do it
and she was just like okay and there are
a lot of times there are a lot of times
too were you know it's debating whether
or not you know she would just like call
it a night you would just stop here and
do another time if you ever tend to do
that don't just do it you know young
filmmakers out there just do it in one
night because it'll be hell that night
but good god you'll really you feel much
better about the next next morning
getting it all done now the fact that I
do you actually find the scary bar go
this video um certain parts
I finally creepy a lot of people that
you find it's scary and I don't know if
I actually find it's scary I do find it
kind of creepy um everything that's
taken from it it's not because a lot of
people are like is taking off the
Simpsons is it's taking off the you know
Chucky or the Twilight sight it guess
it's all that stuff really you know it's
just kind of poking fun at um you know
it's just poking fun of all those you
know doll comes to life all those really
cheesy
you know slasher movie
I never found scary but I guess a lot of
people do so maybe that's why this
worked yeah this isn't that I guess
horror torture porn type category I
guess if I don't even know if that's
what it's called probably not probably
not I don't think Teddy doesn't strip in
this video yeah right right there's no
bondage but oh and the thing here
remember that we tried to do we tried to
put the Y on the mirror but at the blood
when stick you can see right through it
cuz oh yes I did write a Jeff smearing
down yeah so I felt really bad about
that but yeah we started I think 7:00
p.m. and 1:00 to 4:00 a.m. so that's
some that's almost like eight hours I
mean it was uh and it's a few times you
might be this shy you love this shows
rickets and kick me in the nads pretty
much yeah there's a lot of on your own
yeah
and actually we cut right before I pull
back and start laughing rubber pen okay
I just shot like a man that is so much
fun yeah this part definitely not scary
there with you an epic your nan do you
think it was scary I think some people
would definitely yeah that's just
terrifying anytime there's a shot like
that where you just see Teddy looking
with those eyes that that always uh that
that gets a little creeped out I
remember the shut we had to time it just
right
cuz I kept going like you almost bumped
into me yeah times or you would come out
too early and you just look like a
jackass and you know we should talk
about the lighting because you were
going nuts about the lighting cuz I kept
moving the blue light arrived you kept
saying no it has to come from one
sources the people will spotted it to
you as a fraud and of court nobody does
nobody cares good yeah but you were so
convinced I was yeah I put up a fight
for about 10 minutes and I was like you
know what fuck it we're gonna film this
thing tonight we're going to need to be
a team okay so and that the way I did
that there's actually my fingers on the
other side holding that so that's how
bad that knife effect was done you do a
really good job I mean you're you're
very good pretty much just doing it's a
clue what I told you
I just like film this it makes no sense
Douglas but okay no I knew I knew what
it all comes together in the editing
right so that's where yeah that's true
you have to put a lot of trust in the
person because you literally have no
idea what its gonna look like until it's
edited
although the funny thing is that um
after a lot of these toys we did this
Troy grubby is destroyed one of the
Teddy sisters right now wait wait yeah
we're oh yeah yeah the throw that
caterpillar on there that what is that
thing called grubby oh and I actually
hit my toe with the bad it's in one of
the outtakes but I actually hit it yeah
did it hurt that scene where grubby like
bites his leg
I was actually moving that and I just
moved it and I shoved it away so that it
was my hand was off camera if you
remember it now this shows you just how
late we were up because Bargo two of
these shots uh you know we're gonna like
where is where Teddy attacks me you know
he flies onto me and I just used my hand
to fling him onto me remember I told you
I was just like are you sure my hand is
out of the shot yeah yeah it's out of
the shot and I look at it back and it's
like you can see like everything you can
see me just holding this bear so it
looks like I'm just slamming a bear
against my face and obviously I think
you were just absolutely it didn't
register this is the other one when I
punch him and I said you sure you can't
see my face oh yeah yeah yeah in the
shot you can clearly see I'm just
sitting down with it totally punching it
so but but you did good jackass also me
do I apologize you're a bastard but uh
but what but we made something good here
yeah it was it was a lot of fun actually
the one the one downside is that that
really looks like a strobe light and
because it is and that's my fault
because I thought I just told Bargo to
leave it on because the camera only
catches some of the flashes and I just
assumed that would catch every other
flash it wouldn't be a big deal that
totally looks like a strobe light on the
big thing of the teddy ruxpin is that we
actually shot this in order and um this
was made up on the fly this whole little
flying back to the head yeah we don't
know next shot this right here reminds
me of the monolith from
2001 I just wish that you can just hear
like the ladies like oh yeah sure here's
that music action yeah oh you came up
with this idea to heaven cuz originally
we're just gonna have him pointing the
gun at me
from my point of view but we can figure
out how to do it so you have the idea
that it goes in my mouth yeah and then
you just saw this shot this shot which
like the best shot the whole thing was
pretty much you you just looked at the
camera and said alright just stand still
that looks perfect yeah this is just
like we ran out of things to do and it's
like oh well how are we gonna put this
together so just uh you know you've
didn't a ellipse and then boom cut to
this moment and then what what I was
trying to get to is that is that we
actually had to Teddy Ruxpin we have one
that could talk so that one we don't use
with the talking scenes that we another
one that was a stunt bear that we cut
back out and I guess you green-screen
the bear yeah and there's a little face
in there I just found it cuz originally
that was now if you can tell here I
actually got a haircut my sideburns are
really really short the next day so
nobody ever notices that but I could
compare it to the night before at that
joke a lot shorter so that's actually my
brother's idea to put the the devil's
face in there I think well it makes you
seem different which is good I think it
adds to the effect yeah it's true it's
supposed to be afterwards so you got a
haircut along with being possessed yeah
and the stunt bears mouth actually came
off so we had to duct tape it back
together same time you see the bear
after that it's not talking it's just
duct tape in between the lips good times
good times I love you I hate you